the football World Cup begins today in
Qatar while the tournament has been a
lightning rod for criticism due to the
labor and human rights conditions in the
host country fans from around the world
have still been flooding into the Gulf
State so the question is will the most
controversial World Cup in history feel
like all the other World Cups once play
is underway
these scenes are familiar to anyone
who's seen a World Cup football fans
from around the globe arriving at a host
nation in Mass ready to cheer on their
country
foreign
[Applause]
and for the fans that have made the
journey to Qatar the excitement is
palpable
Brazilians are really into this world
cup I think this cup is really going to
surprise everyone
but this world cup is unlike any other
qatar's human rights and labor abuses
have made it the most controversial
World Cup in history something that fans
have to reckon with even if they hope
the tournament can have a positive
impact
it's gonna bring a lot of Joy to the
country and to people to see that Qatar
is not only
controversy because there's been a lot
of issues with the working after 12
years of arduous prep the Qatar World
Cup is here and so are the fans
FIFA recently announced nearly 3 million
tickets more than 90 percent of those
available have already been sold for
many the World Cup still fulfills its
role as a global party bringing people
together
that's the point of the World Cup to get
all the countries together and I'll
share cultures share customs and while a
last minute decision to ban the sale of
alcohol at stadiums might mean beer is a
bit harder to find than at past
tournaments for many it's starting to
feel ever more like a World Cup whether
that impression holds or pressure on
FIFA and Qatar over human rights issues
persist could dictate this tournament's
Legacy
joining me from Doha is DW Sports
correspondent Dania Barcelona Dania
transport us what's the atmosphere like
in Doha right now
so the atmosphere in Doha has really
picked up over the last few days The Fan
Fest have kicked off which means there
are concerts DJs and now it's one of the
only places that you can actually drink
a beer if you have the 14 that it costs
to buy one right now we are in front of
Al bite Stadium where they will be
playing the opening game what you can
see behind me are the last few fans that
are trickling into the stadium not so
many non-match going fans are here
because we are literally in the middle
of the desert as you can see it's pretty
windy right now but the vibe in Doha is
very World Cup like right now
fourteen dollars for a beer okay alcohol
was banned at stadiums just before the
beginning of this tournament to much
criticism as you surely know how are
fans responding now
so some fans are totally okay with the
decision and other fans are a little bit
more disappointed so it was a shock
U-turn decision it just happened a
couple days ago a lot of people are
still processing it but for example
Qatari fans are totally okay with the
decision and tonight you know you see
Qatar against Ecuador Ecuadorian fans on
the other hand are a little bit
disappointed because for them you know
having a beer with friends around the
stadium is a little bit more part of the
match going experience but it is a fresh
decision we don't really know how all
the fans are going to react I'll have to
let you know after the game
Dania people might not know that this is
the host nation's first ever
participation in the World Cup what can
you tell us about the team
a lot of people don't know as much about
Qatar because it's not really a country
with a rich footballing history like in
Argentina or a Brazil but that being
said Qatar has been building their
footballing generation from scratch over
the past 20 years their coach Felix
Sanchez he's really been spearheading
that and they are probably going to be
the most prepared team in the tournament
because they've been together for the
last eight months at a training camp now
that's pretty amazing from footballing
standards the thing is is that they're
the host nation so they're going to have
a lot of pressure on them and in
football pressure can work in two ways
it can either pump you up and Propel you
forward or it can stress you out now in
those times of stress teams usually fall
back on their more experienced players
which in this case Qatar doesn't have so
it'll be interesting tonight to see
which way they go
DW's Dania Barcelona many many thanks